to go and rest - I would just like to
say first of all thank you to all of you
who participated in the charity event so
far it's been really hard warming and
I'm just so happy to see that so many
has been participating in it and helping
out honestly with whatever you have if
it's just a small donation $5 $10 $1 if
there's even to be hundreds of dollars
and thousands of dollars which is crazy
and just sharing the video around you're
helping eventually so thank you honestly
it made me so happy to see I'd honestly
did not expect that you bros are way
more awesome than I thought and we're
gonna do a livestream as I mentioned and
it's gonna go on for a couple hours
there's gonna be a lot of cool youtubers
you're gonna be able to coolest games
and it's gonna be fun so check out the
link in the description
twitch TV twitch.tv slash PewDiePie and
I'll see you there all the cool kids
will be there are you a cool kid well
then you better watch because you're
never gonna be cool unless you watch
cold people playing inside I'm on a
rocking chair by the way hey but maybe I
should just stream this since then all
right I'll see you there